-One of those things
you always say.
You always say to yourself what?
-Oh, gosh. I say...
If you're going to eat gravy,
don't leave it
in your soul patch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's one that's
always gone down.
[ Laughter ]
Where I come from,
everyone says that.
If you're going to eat gravy,
don't leave it
in your soul patch.
-That's right.
-But what if you're eating,
for instance,
a chicken cordon bleu?
[ Laughter ]
That has
some type of thing on there.
You can get something like that.
But that's a good food.
I mean, you you love to go out.
You love to eat.
-I tell you what, I do.
I love to eat.
I love the outdoors.
I mean, honestly, this year,
like towards the end
of the year, I need a break.
What I plan to do
is just go out.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
I want to --
I want to get a fishing rod
and I want to go out. I want to
eat some -- I want to --
I just want to eat
a peanut butter jelly...fish.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Peanut butter jelly...
-Peanut butter jelly/fish.
Yeah.
-Fish.
-That's what you want to do.
Yeah.
Peanut butter and jelly
and fish.
-Or hunt jellyfish.
[ Laughter ]
-Just hunt jellyfish.
I don't think you hunt j--
Do you hunt jellyfish?
-You can hunt anything.
-I can't eat peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches,
so it's a sore subject for me.
-Oh, I'm really sorry.
[ Laughter ]
What can you eat?
-You say why -- You say,
why can't I eat them?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Why?
Why can't you eat
a peanut butter jelly?
[ Laughter ]
-Dentures.
♪♪
Chris Pratt, good to see you
again, my friend.
-Nice to see you.
-You look sharp. You look great.
-Yeah, It's a suit.
-Yeah, it is.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Was the first time we met?
Was it here?
-No.
You know, the first time we met.
You're never going
to remember this.
-Was it September 3rd?
[ Laughter ]
-On Third Street.
-Yes.
-It was during -- It was --
I just got started in Hollywood.
I worked on a TV show.
I got nominated for something
called the Best Sidekick
for like a Teen Choice Awards.
It was a really big deal to me.
I got to take a limo.
It was like all so new
and novel still.
And I had this little bit where
I was like pres-- I didn't win.
The point is, I got nominated
for a Teen Choice Award.
-We get it. You're a big star.
-[ Claps ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. We get it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, yes. Come on. Yes. Yes.
That's really not the point.
The point really
was that afterwards I did
like this little comedy bit
and presented,
and it kind of went
over all right,
but you came up to me
at the end of it and you said,
"Hey, man, great job tonight.
You were really funny tonight."
And it meant so much to me.
It was just so nice to have
someone, like --
[ Audience awws ]
No, really, truly.
Yeah, it was --
-That's cool.
-It was cool
and it just meant a lot to me
because, like, you know,
I knew you from "SNL"
and I knew that you made
a living doing funny things.
And I wanted
to make people laugh.
And it just really meant a lot.
And I think it's cool.
I just think you deserve
all your success
because you were nice to me
and nice people deserve success.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to say
congratulations to you.
It couldn't happen
to a better guy.
Gosh, all these fun
things are happening.
You're doing the new
Jurassic Park movie.
-Yes.
-That's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Thanks, man.
Thanks.
-That's exciting.
-Yeah, I'm excited.
I'm really excited.
Yeah. Jurassic Park.
-And they're filming it
in Hawaii, right?
-Whoo!
-Yes. Yeah.
-That's the bad part.
-Yeah, that's gonna be tough.
They're filming in Hawaii.
Last time I was in Hawaii,
I lived in a van.
Now I'm going back.
I'm the star of Jurassic Park.
-That is so awesome.
-It's gonna be great.
-It is the best country
in the whole wide world.
I love America.
-I'm moving back to the van.
I'm going to have them
rent the van out.
I'm moving in with my family.
-Didn't you work at a Bubba
Gump Shrimp Company?
-Yeah, Bubba Gump
Shrimp Company in Maui.
I worked there.
-That's one of my
favorite theme restaurants.
-It's the best theme.
It's one of my
favorite theme restaurants, too.
-Do you have to ask
Forrest Gump trivia to people?
-Oh, yeah. That was
one of the conceptual musts.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-Is that what they call them?
-Yeah, yeah. There were
four of them, I think.
-Do you remember any of
the trivia questions at all?
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
What did Forrest Gump
drink when he met the president?
-Oh, I remember.
He drank like a bunch of them.
Dr Pepper?
-Dr Peppers.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The folks at Lego
made something for you.
-They did?
-Yeah.
And we're going
to give it to you.
I've been asked to give it
to you.
-That's very nice.
-So I think they said
it's maybe back here.
Okay. I think I might get it.
Okay.
Don't look. Don't look. Okay.
-Oh, wow.
-To commemorate this big moment
for you, Jimmy,
and going to
"The Tonight Show,"
the folks at Lego made this
for you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love it.
-Isn't that cool?
-I was kind of like
the Lorne Michaels
of the leadership class.
I was like,
"All right, guys,
this one goes in.
This one is cut,
this one stays."
And I would sort of be
in charge of the assemblies.
-You would do skits for people?
-We would do skits for people
in front of the school.
And by the end of the week,
it would always be
the same thing,
which was just a skit
starring me that I'd ripped off
from "SNL" the week before.
[ Laughter ]
-Word for word?
-Yeah. Yes.
Like, with giving "SNL"
no credit.
-No, no, no. Yeah.
-Just being like,
"Come on, guys. I came up
with something last night.
Let's just go for it.
It's called
a cheerleader sketch.
I'm gonna play like
a gregarious cheerleader.
Chrissy Barr, you're going
to play my sidekick.
And then this is
what it looks like."
They're like, "Uh, yeah.
From 'SNL,'
the Will Ferrell-Cheri Oteri.'"
-So I'll be playing Cheri Oteri
and you'll be playing
Will Ferrell.
-"I don't know
what you're talking about.
All right, guys,
we're on in three, two."
And they're like...
-And then it worked.
And now look where you are.
-Now I'm doing the real show.
-Oh, it's so exciting. I cannot
wait. I'm so happy for you.
-And it's just as fun as when I
did it in high school.
-I mean, it is, right?
-Yeah. Yeah, I think.
-Hey, I want to know.
I want to know
about this guy here.
I saw you. Who's this guy?
[ Cheers, whistling
and applause ]
I just have to know
the story behind it.
I want to know what's going on.
Where were you? Were you okay?
[ Laughter ]
Did anyone help you?
What was this? What was this?
-This is -- Okay.
[ Laughs ]
I was 20 years old
in that picture.
I guess it was the year 2000.
I just moved to L.A.
I knew I wanted to be an actor.
I had no idea what to do
to become an actor.
I had a car and that was it.
-That's a big deal.
Even having a car is a big deal.
-Yeah.
And I'd ask around
and my friend said,
"What you need is something
called a headshot.
And that's a picture
of your head."
[ Laughter ]
"And then you send it
out to people.
They're like,
'Hey, that's a good head.
I'll look and meet him.'
You know?"
-Yeah, I'll put that head
in my movie. Yeah.
-Yeah. So I knew I needed
a headshot
and I was in an area of
L.A. called West Hollywood,
which you know West Hollywood.
It's a great part of Hollywood,
predominantly gay area.
-Yeah.
-Really kind of
a fabulous place.
I was at the post office.
There's a guy who is like
looking at me
for a long time
and he was like,
"You look familiar.
Have I shot you before?"
And I was like,
"Oh, I've never been shot."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-"Have you shot somebody?"
I don't think
you've ever shot me.
-Either way, I'm fine.
-I would know.
-I would never press charges.
-Yeah.
-I'm fine.
-He was like,
"I'm a photographer."
In my head, I'm like,
"Do you do headshots?"
He's like, "Yeah. My apartment
is two blocks from here."
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"Let's go, let's go."
[ Laughter ]
So I walk over to the apartment.
This guy's got like
a penthouse suite, really nice.
He's like, "You probably need
to take a shower.
You're a little messed up."
He was right. He was right.
I lived in the car.
♪♪
Hey, I'm just
painting a picture here.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So I took the shower,
I got cleaned up.
I did my hair,
as you can see.
Like, you know,
picked it out a little.
And then he was like,
"That shirt's not going to do.
Here's one of mine."
He gave me this shirt
that's in the picture.
It's a white shirt.
-That's his shirt?
-It's a nice shirt.
I couldn't afford that shirt.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I had that shirt.
And then he takes the pictures.
He tells me what to do, tilt
my head, put my arm like this,
takes the film out of the
camera, sticks it in the thing.
He hands me three rolls
of camera film,
which at the time
would have cost me like 400,
500 bucks, you know, like head
shots are not inexpensive.
And he was like,
"Good luck, kid."
And I walked out of there
and then I decided
that this was the best one.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a great story.
-Yeah.
-He's a good guy.
-He is a good guy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's a good -- That's a good --
-So if you're watching,
dude, if you remember,
thank you, man. Thank you.
-You made his career, man.
-You did. That got me on the WB.
That got me "Everwood."
That was that headshot
that got me "Everwood."
-Hey, that's awesome, buddy.
-Pretty cool.
-Three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
And three, two, one.
-Three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah! Oh, my God!
-We should do a triple piggyback
in one of these.
-And three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dude, this next one,
we're getting lei'd.
-All right. Big smile.
And three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
Three, two, one.
One more. Three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Never been done before.
The triple hoagie.
-All right. And big smile.
And three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Is it crazy to just have
that come out of my fly?
Here.
-I think that is the best thing
I've ever heard in my life.
-And big smiles.
And three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
Gonna get another one like that.
And three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
Three, two, one.
Let's get one more.
And three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Oh, my God. Jimmy Fallon.
-What's up, my man? Holy God.
Captain America.
-Captain America.
-You want to jump over
my shoulders?
-I can. If you just
drop your head, I can get up.
-Three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
Three, two, one.
-Oh, my God!
-Seahawk fans!
-Let's get a group shot.
-Everybody say "Super Bowl."
-Super Bowl!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-I worked at a place
called the Viking Drive In.
I like flipped burgers
at a little tiny
drive-through burger joint.
-Fun.
-It was awesome.
-Yeah.
-It was great.
I could walk,
I could rollerblade there.
I rollerbladed everywhere
as a kid.
I mean, I'm painting
a pretty awesome picture.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Who I was as a kid.
-You were a cool kid, man.
-Really cool.
Super cool.
-So cool.
-It was really fun. It was --
The Viking Drive--
-You would operate
the drive-through?
-I would operate
the drive-through.
I'd take people's orders.
It was right kitty-corner
to this place
called the Mini Mart,
which was like the hangout
for -- it was a small town,
maybe 7,000 people
when I lived there.
And Lake Stevens, Washington,
and people would go
get out of their car
and go into the mini mart
and I would be hidden
in the Viking Drive In
over the intercom
and I would mess with them.
I'd be like,
"Hey, buddy, I need your help."
[ Laughter ]
-People looking around.
"Who's saying that?"
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
-I'd be like, "It's me. God."
[ Laughter ]
It was awesome.
-Coming from a drive-through
speaker like, "This is the
calling, God talking to me."
-It was pretty great.
-But it must have been good
to have your own
pocket money at 14.
-Yeah. Yeah, it was good.
Well, here's a lesson I learned
because the lady who
who owned the place was like,
"Listen, if you ever
want to eat something,
you just eat something.
Just make sure
you write it down.
We'll give it you for half price
and then we'll just
take it out of your check."
I was like, "Cool." So it was
kind of a credit system.
-Yeah.
-And I worked there -- I think
I got paid every two weeks
and I got my first check
and they were like,
"Okay, let's just see.
Here's what you got.
Oh, you owe us $80."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "What?! How is that
possible?"
-You owe them.
-I owed them $80.
-You ate a lot of burgers.
-I ate a lot of stuff.
-Yeah, that's good stuff.
-It was good stuff.
-And how about your son now?
How old is your son now?
-He's now two and a half.
-Two and a half.
-And he's going to work, right?
Is he going to?
-Yeah, we're trying to
get him jobs now.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What is he doing?
Is he saying things?
-Man, he loves trucks.
He loves everything
trucks, cars, automobiles.
He -- He thinks...
He thinks I'm a firefighter.
[ Laughter ]
-Why?
-I don't know.
Because I know this.
Because I'll say,
"Hey, bud, I'm going
to be back tomorrow.
I got to go to work,"
and he'll go,
"Um, are -- are you going to
work on your fire truck?"
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like..."Yes, I am."
"Yes, I am, son."
-You just go,
"Yeah, sure. Of course."
-Hi, Santa.
-Hello, Ding Dongs.
[ Laughter ]
-You're looking at me like I'm
on your naughty list.
-Well, I was counting my toys
and was one doinker short.
I believe you stole it.
-But, Papa...
-I started making that toy in
200 A.D.
What will the little Jennifer
Lawrences think when she wakes
up on Christmas morning with
nothing under the apple tree?
[ Laughter ]
-I would never steal
such a demure toy.
[ Laughter ]
-Where were you the night before
Christmas?
-I was with Pickles.
We were listening to The Roots'
holiday album
and making snow gerbils.
[ Laughter ]
-Nice.
-Pickles is very...
-Hmm. Mm-hmm!
Then why did Rudolph see you
spanking on the roof?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
22 centuries before the toy was
missing.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a coincidence.
-The reason I work so hard is
because I get to spread joy
to millions of people and go sit
by the fire, shaking my nad.
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-The little...
-I know, I know, I know.
-Tiny, little guy.
-Yeah, yeah.
-While eating cookies and
drinking Milwaukee's Best Ice.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Fine.
I stole the toy.
[ High-pitched ]
But I only did it...
-Wait.
[ Laughter ]
-I was using a fake voice
earlier.
-Oh.
-I'm an elf.
I forgot I was an elf.
-Oh, right.
Oh, and I'm Santa.
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho!
-That's right.
-Ding Dongs. Ho-ho.
You're silly.
-I sold the toy.
I only did it because I wanted
to impress my pediatrician.
[ Laughter ]
-Ugh! Ugh! Ugh!
Every time there's
a holiday miracle,
I sing my favorite Christmas
song, "Jingle Forks."
[ Laughter ]
[ Bells jingling ]
♪ Jingle forks, jingle forks ♪
♪ Jingle all the way ♪
♪ Oh, what fun it is to ride ♪
♪ In a one-horse open starship ♪
-Merry Christmas, Santa!
-Scene!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you a karaoke guy?
Did I ask you that last time?
-I don't know if you did,
but I am a karaoke guy.
I mean, who doesn't --
Do you guys like karaoke?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, I've sang karaoke
for a long time.
My whole family. We always sing
karaoke at parties.
-Do you have a go-to song?
-Well, yeah, I did.
I had a go-to song that
for a while I felt like
I murdered "Man in the Mirror."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Michael Jackson?
-Michael Jackson.
-That's a classic.
-I know. And then I realized...
I have to tell you this story.
The time I realized that
I don't murder Michael Jackson
singing karaoke, I went
to -- I had killed it one week.
I felt really good. I was like,
"Oh, that's my song."
[ Laughter ]
-"I'm the next Michael Jackson."
-"I can sing
'Man in the Mirror.'"
-That's a tricky song.
-Very difficult,
high degree of difficulty.
But when you nail it,
you nail it.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I was riding high on the wave
of nailing "Man in the Mirror"
the week before.
-Yeah.
-Went to the new karaoke bar.
Met a girl.
-Oh, yeah.
-Her name was Marina.
Do you remember Marina?
I was flirting with her.
I had "Man in the Mirror"
in my pocket.
I knew I was going to kill it.
Put "Man in the Mirror" in.
I got up on stage.
I said -- [ Laughs ]
This is true, by the way.
I know I'm playing it up.
But this was a really
a vulnerable moment for me.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you for telling me this.
-I said...
"This song is for Marina."
I swear to God.
And then
the first note came out.
And I didn't
realize there's different notes
and different keys and stuff,
and it just wasn't my key.
It wasn't my night.
And it came out and it was like
I was like...
[ Vocalizes ]
♪ I'm gonna make a cha--♪
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-That's when you knew
you couldn't do it?
-It didn't match, you know,
the sound didn't line up.
-Oh, no.
-And I was like...
♪ For once in my ♪
"You suck!"
[ Laughter ]
And I just immediately
started sweating.
Some guy yelled, "You suck."
And I look and he was standing
right next to Marina.
[ Audience ohhs ]
And she left
with the "you suck" guy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba ]
I've never sang "Man
in the Mirror" since, man.
It hurt. It hurt so bad.
-She left with the
"you suck" guy.
Yeah. Well, no.
How is the family?
How old is your son?
-He turned four. He's about
almost four and a half.
-Wow.
-Yeah, he's just great, man.
-Isn't it cool?
-It is cool.
-I mean,
I have three and a two,
but it's just every day
is a new fun thing.
Do they know that
you're in movies?
Does he understand that yet?
-He does, but he
doesn't, you know. It's not --
The other day he went
to Universal Studios.
You know, we were both
in "Jurassic World."
Yes. And he --
-Number-one movie of all time.
-He went to --
He went and they have a guy
there dressed up like my
character from "Jurassic World."
And he does the thing
with the raptors
and they have like these
fake dinosaurs that come out
and this guy pretends
to be that character
and amuses the people
who come to Universal Studios.
And he came home
and he's like, "Dad.
I met the real
'Jurassic World' guy."
[ Laughter ]
-I'm like, "That guy? No!"
-"I'm the real guy."
-He's like, "No, no, no, no, no.
He doesn't do it on TV.
He's the real guy.
I think it's the character
your guy is based on."
-He met the real one, man.
-He met the real --
He met the real
"Jurassic World" guy,
so he was pretty thrilled.
Yeah, same at Legoland.
He's like, "Dad, Emmet's here.
The real Emmet, not you,
the real one."
I'm like, "Come on, man."
-Come on, come on.
Give Dad something.
-I think he knows.
I think he's just being mean.
-He's just playing with you.
Yeah.
-[ Humming ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Jimmy humming ]
Okay.
♪♪
Now, you can either lie about
this or you can tell the truth.
It's up to you.
Tell me what the object is,
or you can tell me --
You can tell me
what the object --
-It's, uh -- Is this real?
-No, look at me. All right.
-This is a small...
diorama...
of little people, dwarves.
-Dwarves.
-Engaging in...
-Oh, my goodness.
-No.
-...stretching, yoga.
And...
they're all wearing hats.
[ Laughter ]
-All right,
so you're telling me --
You're telling me that
what is in front of you...
[ Laughter ]
...is a diorama of sorts,
which is something
I normally would make
in a shoe box, perhaps,
maybe when I was growing up,
which is maybe
why you thought of that,
because we have a box
and you thought of a shoe box,
and then made up a lie
about a diorama,
which makes me think,
Chris Pratt, you lie!
[ Audience cheers ]
-Sucka!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. That was well done.
-Yes.
-You had such a great year.
I know you've been
all around the world,
but you were in
"Avengers: Infinity War,"
...which has crushed
at the box office.
Continues to crush.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-And then all these --
a whole lot of coincidences
started happening.
-Whoa.
-Here's you with the comic book.
-Yeah, look at this.
-Can you explain this story now?
-Yeah, you got
to hear this story.
-All right.
-So this is me, just recently,
around Christmastime,
and I have here the comic book,
"The Infinity Gauntlet."
-Okay.
-Okay, when I was a kid,
I was collecting comic books.
I was about 13 years old, but I
actually loved comic books.
I didn't have any, 'cause they
were expensive, you know?
It was like
5 bucks apiece or something.
My friends Travis and Forrest,
they collected
"Wolverine" and "Punisher,"
and they each had a number 1.
And I was like,
"You got to get a number 1,"
'cause I thought
a number 1 comic book,
that's going to put you
through college one day.
If you have the number 1,
then you'll sell it
for $10,000 one day,
and you'll be set for life.
-Yeah.
-So, I went to --
I went to bingo with my mom.
[ Laughter ]
And this story --
-As kids do.
-As one does.
-Yes.
-Accompanied mom
to the gambling hall.
-A little bingo time.
-And she let me play,
and I picked my own numbers,
and for one game,
the pick eight, I could play,
and I won $300, and I went and
I spent it all on comic books,
just blew the entire check,
and I got all these number 1s,
including this one, right here,
"The Infinity Gauntlet."
-Which is --
-Which is, like, a really
crucial story element
in the "Infinity War" film.
So my brother dug that up,
and he was like,
"Dude, did you know we have --
You bought that comic book
when you were a kid."
And so, this is where
it starts to get weird.
I was in London, and I was
at this Bellator MMA fight.
It's kind of like an MMA,
kind of like the UFC,
a big fight.
-Yep.
-And this guy --
-You're into that, you love it.
-I love that stuff, yeah.
And these guys just beat
the crap out of each other.
I was having
the time of my life.
I was sitting next to 50 Cent.
It was like,
"My life is so awesome."
They were playing 50 Cent,
and I was sitting next to him.
-Was he going to the music,
or was he just cool?
-Yeah, I just looked at him,
I was like,
"They're playing your music."
He's like,
"Yeah, I know that's my music."
But I was just having
the time of my life.
And the guy who won,
this champion,
named Michael "Venom" Page,
comes out,
and they bring him
an Infinity Gauntlet,
and they slide it on his hand,
and he's the victor.
And he looks and notices me,
and points to me
outside of the cage.
And meanwhile,
50 Cent is playing,
and 50 Cent is right next to me.
[ Laughter ]
And the guy's
got an Infinity Gauntlet,
and it was like déjà vu.
It was one of those moments
where your life
and your destiny intersect.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I mean --
-And I -- And it was just
the craziest thing.
I thought for certain
I was gonna wake up.
-Lookit!
-Where would you just have
something like this
lying around?
-He didn't know
I was gonna be there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He did not know.
-Didn't know.
And I was like, honestly, I --
Part of me in that moment
was like, "Oh, crap.
This is a dream."
[ Laughter ]
"This whole thing's
been a dream.
I'm gonna wake up,
living in a tent."
[ Laughter ]
"And this whole 20 years
has been a dream."
-Yeah.
-"A big fever dream."
An awesome dream.
I'd be so gutted if I woke up
and it was gone.
-Your dream is like,
you got "Parks and Rec"...
-I got "Parks and Rec," yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, I moved to --
I moved to Hollywood.
-Moved to Hollywood.
-The whole thing wouldn't --
It makes sense.
It could still happen.
You, I'd be like,
"The guy from 'SNL'
was hosting the show that
Johnny Carson used to host."
-The guy that laughed at himself
his entire life
is now hosting
"The Tonight Show"?
-He's now hosting
"The Tonight Show."
-I love that you created us.
-Yeah.
-I love that you created
a back career for my career.
-Thank you.
It's a good dream.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, all right.
3, 2, 1, go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
Holding in a yawn?
-Unh-unh.
-[ Laughs ]
I was like...
That was a good yawn!
-I didn't even do
"holding in a yawn."
I just tried
to make you me laugh.
-You made me laugh.
All right,
that's an interesting strategy.
I like that.
I was actually
trying to swallow one.
All right.
Let's do another one here.
This is...
"pretending you love a present."
-Oh, got it, got it.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
Three, two, one.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I did the same face.
[ Both laugh ]
-That was a good bit.
You did the same face!
That's so funny!
Gosh, that's such
a good strategy.
-I won't do it --
-No, but that was so funny.
Your "pretending
to hold a yawn" face.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the only face you make.
It's very funny.
-I won't do it again.
That's good.
Here we go.
Let's do another one.
[ Laughter ]
"Cinco de Mayo at 3:00 a.m."
-Oh, yeah!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
All right, three, two, one.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
Stop doing that.
Stop doing that!
[ Both laugh ]
-All right, all right.
I'm gonna actually do
a real one this time.
[ Laughter ]
-It's so stupid,
it makes me laugh.
Oh, I love it.
All right, here's one.
There's one more round.
Here's the last one here.
This one is --
Oh, you'll be good at this.
-Yeah, I got this one.
-"Velociraptor is standing
right behind you."
-Like, you're trying
to convey to a person
that they're standing
right behind you, or --
Yeah, yes, 'cause otherwise,
you wouldn't know
if it was standing behind you.
-No, I think you would know.
-I'm telling you
that a velociraptor
is standing behind you,
or am I just --
-Would you know?
-'Cause if they're standing
behind you, I'd just be making
this face.
I wouldn't know.
-I know, but what --
-They're sneaky.
-Oh, they are sneaky.
-I wouldn't know.
-You wouldn't really know?
-I'd know.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
I'm a scientist.
I know these things.
A velociraptor is standing
behind me, and I know.
-Okay.
So, the idea is that
I'm gonna have to do it --
My thing is, I'm gonna
be telling you that there is
a velociraptor behind you,
like, over there.
-Or is it that
that's happening, and you're
like, "What just happened?"
[ Laughter ]
Like, I don't think it's just --
"I don't know
what's standing behind me."
Is there something behind me?
-Can we get a ruling?
[ Laughter ]
-Is there something
behind me right now?
-Yeah, that's gonna be the face.
I'm doing there's a velociraptor
standing behind you.
-Oh, I'm doing there's a
velociraptor standing behind me.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah, all right.
-Yeah, yeah.
-We got this.
-Oh, no, you're right.
It's standing right behind you.
-Like, there's a velo--
Is it in quotes?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
"You" is in quotes.
-Yeah.
-It's standing behind "you."
Yeah, "you" is in quotes.
-Is there an emphasis?
[ Laughter ]
-There's an emphasis
on "behind."
Okay. Ready?
-Let's poll the audience.
Do you have "Millionaire"
technology?
Can we poll the audience?
-Here we go.
-Oh, God.
-"Velociraptor standing
right behind you."
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
Same thing as me.
Okay. Behind you.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Three, two, one.
[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
I knew you were gonna do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Chris Pratt, everybody!
That's how you do it.
That's how you make me laugh.
Oh, you're a funny dude.
Love you, bud.
Oh, I love that little lapel
pin.
-Thank you. It's a mushroom.
-I love it. I get it. I get it.
-Because --
-No, no, I understand.
-No, because --
-No, no, no. I understand.
Don't explain. No, no, no.
You like mushrooms.
-Yeah.
-That's right. Yeah.
Last time you were here,
we had the best time.
I appreciate you
coming to the show.
And you were very nervous
and excited because your wife,
Katherine, was very pregnant
and was about to have a baby.
-That's right.
-And you had your phone out.
-Just in case.
-You go, "Just in case anything
goes down just
during this interview."
And...?
-We had a deal that if she was
born while I was on the show
that I would name her Jimmy.
-Questlove?
[ Drum roll ]
-She's named Eloise 'cause she
was not born...
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Wow.
[ Sad tuba ]
Beautiful name, though.
No, no, beautiful.
-Bohm-bohm!
Boo, Eloise!
-No, no, no!
-One day you'll see this,
and you'll know that I wish
your name was Jimmy...
-No, we love you.
-...not Eloise!
-Eloise. Wait. That's beautiful.
-Isn't that beautiful? Yeah.
-You are now the father of
three.
Does that ever sink in, bud?
-Wow.
-This is -- You're a dad.
-Whew!
-Yeah. I mean...
-Yeah. Thank you.
-You're a fun dad.
-I love it, man.
Yeah, I have --
-You have a 10...
-I got a 10-year-old, 2 1/2,
and 10 months.
-Ooh!
-The 10-year-old is my son Jack.
And then Lyla and Eloise,
the two girls.
-How's Lyla doing?
-Oh, my gosh.
She's -- She's the best.
She's so girly. She's so cute.
She loves dresses and bows
and all of the princessy stuff.
Pink is her favorite color.
And she loves to chat.
She's a real chatterbox.
She'll talk -- She was talking
to my sister on FaceTime,
and then my sister later said,
she goes, "Lyla is like
the personification of a Mad Lib
'cause she knows all these
words, but she doesn't quite
know how to really use them."
So she'll -- The other day,
she said, "Daddy, Daddy.
I'm going to Palm Beach
in two minutes!"
[ Laughter ]
I said, "You are?"
She said, "Yes.
I'm going with Santa Claus.
We are going to bring
all of the sand."
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I was like, "That's exactly
a Mad Lib."
-Give me a noun. Give me a noun.
-Give me an adjective.
-Yeah.
And how's Grandpa?
Arnold Schwarzenegger
is your grandpa.
-Yeah. He goes by "Opa."
-Oh.
-You know, he's Austrian.
German. "Opa" is "grandfather"
in German.
So he goes by "Opa."
-[ As Arnold ]
Did he have a cigar?
-Oh. [ Laughs ]
-Did you have a cigar with him?
-Yes. Yes.
-Yes. You had the cigar?
-Yeah.
-[ Normal voice ]
He loves his cigar.
-He loves his cigar.
-He came on the show.
He taught me
how to smoke a cigar.
-Yeah, he kind of taught me,
too.
I mean, there's nothing manlier
than Arnold Schwarzenegger
smoking a cigar.
And when you're part of, you
know, bringing his granddaughter
into the world, he comes
and he brings you a cigar
and he's like, "Let's go out
and smoke these."
And I was like, "Okay,"
but I have asthma,
so I don't like cigars.
And I was like,
"You got it, Arnold."
And Katherine's like,
"What are you doing?"
I was like, "I'm fine.
I'm gonna be okay."
And so I go and I smoke
the cigar
and I'm like, "This is good.
[ Coughs ]
Hmm. Oh, yeah.
Cohiba? Nice."
And then woke up the next day.
Massive lung infection, but...
[ Laughter ]
Worth it.
-You always have to --
If Arnold says,
"Let's smoke a cigar..."
-You go, "Okay."
-Let's do it. Yeah.
You go, "Yeah."
-There's peer pressure,
and then there's...
-Arnold Schwarzenegger.
-...Arnold Schwarzenegger
pressure.
-No, you do whatever --
He came on.
I said I want to understand it
and how to do it and everything,
because I smoked
a couple of cigars.
I don't know when. And I'm
like -- You bite the end off
and then you, like,
lick the side.
He goes [As Arnold] "You don't
bite and lick it.
What are you talking about?
You don't lick the cigar!
You don't lick it and bite it!"
[ Normal voice ]
I go, "I think I did."
He's like, "No!" He goes,
[As Arnold] "Next time I'm in
town, I'll teach you.
I'll take you to a cigar bar,
and I'll teach you how."
[ Normal voice ] I go --
And he's a man of his word.
Called me on the phone.
-No.
-Said, "Jimmy, it's Arnold.
I'm going to a cigar bar."
And I was with -- I was with
Drew Barrymore and my wife,
and I go, "Do you guys want to
go to a cigar bar
with Arnold Schwarzenegger?"
They're like, "Let's do it."
We showed up,
and we all smoked cigars.
-Come on.
-It was the best.
Love that dude. Congrats, Opa.
Opa?
-Opa Arnold.
-Congratulations, Opa.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Stogies.
-Congrats to you and Katherine.
-Thanks, man. Thank you.
Yeah, we're blessed.
We feel very blessed.
-Good, nice parents.
I want to talk
"Super Mario Bros."
because that is --
That's the jam.
I'm excited about
this Wednesday.
-Let's go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm excited.
-Go see it.
-You're Mario.
-I'm Mario.
I'm the voice of Mario.
-So what happens when you get
the phone call and they're like,
"Hey, would you like to be
this iconic..."
-I'm like, "Pfft. No."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Exactly.
-I was like, "Oh, my God!
Really?!"
Yeah, I mean, you get that call.
And it's just really exciting
because, I mean, if you think
about it, all the IP that's out
there, anything that has reach,
it's already been remade.
It's already been turned into
a TV show or a movie.
And for some reason,
the Super Mario Bros.
hasn't been a movie
for almost 30 years.
And it's because I think the
folks at Nintendo just didn't
want to give anybody the
permission to make the movie,
and so finally they made...
-Oh, Illumination is --
-Illumination, you know --
"Despicable Me,"
"Secret Life of Pets."
-"Minions." Brilliant.
-"Minions."
Incredible studio.
And so they partnered up
and they decided that they were
going to make this movie.
And so when something like that
comes around, it's just like --
you're so blessed, so honored
to do it, I mean, for me...
-It's fantastic.
It's gonna crush, buddy.
And, you know, I was thinking
about you
because I was watching it,
and there's a lot of action.
There's a lot of action
in this movie.
And I could just kind of hear
you -- a lot of grunting by you.
-Yes.
-Going like...
[ Grunting ]
And I go -- I was like -- "Oh,
maybe Chris will bring footage,"
of you doing those grunts
when you come on the show.
I just want to see you in
the sound booth going like...
[ Both grunting ]
-Well, you know, here's
an interesting thing
about that, actually.
Usually the effort sounds you do
at the end of the session.
You probably do like one or two
sessions a month over the course
of a couple years to voice one
of these movies.
And at the end, because
the efforts and the grunts
and the screaming, that really
takes it out of your voice,
they save that for the end.
But here's an interesting
little tidbit.
In a -- What makes physical
comedy work in
like a "Tom and Jerry"
or a "Super Mario Bros."
is when a character falls
a long way and hits,
they don't die, right?
If they died, it would --
If Tom and Jerry --
If, like, Road Runner -- If,
like, the anvil hit his head
and there's freaking brains
everywhere...
-No, no, no, no, no.
That'd be terrible.
[ Laughter ]
-Be like, "Oh, my God!"
That'd be bad, right?
-Terrible idea. Terrible.
-So in order to let kids know
that the character's not dead...
-Yes.
-...you have to do an,
"I'm okay, I'm alive" sigh.
"I'm hurt, not injured" sigh.
So it's like this.
You're like, "Aaaaaah!"
Unh!
Uhh...
-Yeah!
[ Applause ]
-Without that...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It just goes, hey, it's a joke,
everybody.
-Kids will be like,
"Mario is dead!
Mario fell to his death, Dad!"
-That's so funny.
It's so well-done.
It's such a great cast.
Everyone's so talented and good.
A lot of fun people.
-Good luck.
-Super Mario Bros.
-Boom! Let's see the answer!
[ Ding! ]
Yes! Super Mario Bros.!
-Wow.
That was a hard question.
-How was that a hard question?
-James. Oh, yo!
[ Mario power-up sound plays ]
-[ Laughs ]
-How was that a hard question?
It's basically every video game
right there.
-Right. It was hard.
That was a difficult question.
-Alright.
-Now, here's your question.
-Yeah. Oh, good luck.
-Good luck, James.
-Yeah.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Who's the creator?
-I mean, I'm a Nintendo nerd.
I'm going to say Miyamoto?
-Judges?
[ Drum roll ]
[ Ding! ]
Yes!
Shigeru Miyamoto.
Chris. Ready?
[ Mario power-up sound plays ]
[ Grunts ]
He's more man than you. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-Wow.
-Hurt my leg.
-My God.
-Oy!
-God.
-[ Laughing ]
Chris?
-Yes.
-This is a hard one.
-Pfft!
-Travel across 1800s America?
-Yeah.
-Okay, now I'm going to phone
a friend on this -- uh, myself.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Hello? Yeah, uh, is that --
I think it's, uh, Oregon Trail?
-Let's see.
Let's see the answer.
[ Ding! ]
Oregon Trail! Yes!
-Hey! I played that at school.
-Oh, my God.
-I played that in school.
-You died of dysentery.
You got a snake bite.
-Oh, yeah, you died
of a snake bite.
-Ready, Jimmy? You're going up.
[ Mario power-up sound plays ]
Ohhhhh, my gosh!
Okay, Jimmy, next question is
for you.
You know this.
-Well, first, I want to give
a shout-out to my...
-[ Laughs ]
-...my buddy Weasel back at home
in Boston.
You know I love you, Weaz.
Uh, you're talking about
EA Sports. Come on, dude.
-All right, let's see
the answer.
-Electronic Arts.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay, Chris.
Oh, my God. So close.
[ Mario power-up sound plays ]
-Aaaah!
-♪ So close ♪
-If it's in the game --
-Alright, Chris.
Next question is to you.
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
-Not What, like his name.
What is his name?
It's not What.
-Blinky.
-Inky.
-Pinky and...
[ Drum roll ]
It's got to rhy-- I don't know.
I'm going to have
to take a guess.
Uh, Juanita?
-[ Laughs ]
-Juanita.
[ Sad tuba ]
Jimmy, do you know the answer?
-I do, but it's not --
It doesn't rhyme.
It's like Gary or something.
Or Paul or something.
-Let's see.
Judges, let's see the answer.
-If it's Gary,
I'm gonna be upset.
-It's Clyde!
Oh, Chris. One more.
Ohh, so close!
[ Mario power-up sound plays ]
-Oh, my God.
-All right, Jimmy.
-[ Laughs ]
-Next question is for you.
-Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Clyde.
Yes. Yes.
-...not Trump...
-Q-Bert.
Who changes co--
You're just gonna jump
right on it? Q-Bert?
Let's see the answer.
[ Ding! ]
Yes!
Q-Bert.
♪♪
[ Mario power-up sound plays ]
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my gosh. Chris.
-Are you kidding me?
-Next question is for you.
-What, does his head gotta go
in the pipe?!
-Well, he's got to go
in the pipe.
And that's not -- Trust me.
-For heaven's sakes.
-You don't want to get that
dumped on your head.
[ Balloon pops ]
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Mario coins rapidly dinging ]
-Wow!
His laughter! His laughter!
His laughter,
that's what got him!
He's a good sport.
-Let's see a slow-mo of that!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
-Chris Pratt, everybody.